كما قالت مندوبه الوليه
في مقابله مع الجزيره ان القرار اسقاط
عضويه ايران في لجنه الامم المتحده
المعنيه بوضع المراه يمثل رساله قويه
لطهرانه وان التحرك الامريكي بهذا الشان
لا علاقه له باي ضغوط على ايران بشان
البرنامج النووي بل لدفع الايران كي تفعل
ما هو صائما حقوق المراه حسبه
فقط صوتوا ضد القرار لذلك كانت رساله قويه
واعتقد ان التصويت حقق ما كان يريد منه
وهو اخراج ايران من اللجنه المعنيه بوضع
المراه كان انتصارا مدويا اعتقد ان القرار
سيغير الوضع على الارض واعتقد ان الرساله
التي يواجهها الى الحكومه الايرانيه هي
انه لا يمكنك الاستمرار في الانخراط فيما
تقوم به من هجمات ضد المتظاهرين ولا يتم
ادانتك من قبل العالم وما حدث هنا لا
علاقه له بالاتفاق النووي بل له علاقه
بالوضع على الارض في ايران حاليا فهذا ما
نركز عليه وليس صفقه نعم
من جانبه قال مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي جاكسون ان تصويت الامم المتحده
لازاله ايران من لجنه وضع المراه تاريخي
واشاره على الاجماع الدوليه للمتزايد ضد
طيران واكد سوليفان بلاده ستعمل مع
شركائها لمحاسبته ايران على الانتهاكات
التي ترتكبها ضد شعبها ولا سيما ضد
المتظاهرين السلميين ووافق تقديره واضاف
ان ما سماه عمليات الاعدام المروعه
الاخيره في طيران لا تؤدي الا الى تقويه
العزم على توسيع الاجماع المتزايد
واعتباعي اليات محاسبه للنظام الايراني
والمسؤولين عن الفضاء حسب تصريحات